you've been in the business forever how
were you 11. yeah jodie foster um
on panic room got me a mariachi band for
my 11th birthday so that's how i
remember when i started acting i was
like okay i did one movie before that
11 years old in the business finding
success early on um you know i guess the
easy question is
excited at the time or was it so much
you know like where were you at with the
understanding of what was happening i
just wanted to like hang out and make
movies yeah because my parents did that
and
um i wanted so badly to just be a part
of the crew okay i wanted to make movies
so badly and my mom was a script
supervisor and my dad was a uh like a
stage manager for forever for my whole
business you grew up in the business i
grew up waiting for my parents to come
home with little mini candy bars from
craft service since i was like you know
born
and their jobs were
something that they i could tell they
loved it so much
and that it seemed sort of odd because
everyone else's parents were like
are you okay like your parents are never
really around i'm like i know my parents
better than your kids know you like i i
see them when i get up and i run to them
at midnight and i go like dude what did
you do today and they're like hey
boomeister well let me tell you about my
day like
i loved the stories and i was like i
don't want to do anything other than be
close to that
and as a kiddo obviously you have to be
an actor i couldn't have been the prop
guy as like you know an 11 year old it's
so crazy because i just had a i had a
guest on who said the opposite
um you know they found success later on
but their problem was they said with
their parents it felt like
they weren't there and there was a there
was a hurt because of the absence there
was understanding because of the work
that was being done but they were very
vocal about like wow in that time i felt
like i was missing the love in this case
you're like no dude the relationship
that we had was so dope because i felt
like i was a part of what they were
doing i remember
distinctly when i was like
i think five years old because it was
kind of when kindergarten was a hell of
a memory yeah that's a hell of a meaning
but my mom was like in thailand or
something for three months
and i remember just like hating this
three-month period but being kind of
like
i don't know this sounds weird but like
stoked for her couldn't wait for her to
come home i was like i had this one
picture that i still have of her like on
my nightstand
and
i guess for a five-year-old a
three-month period away from your mom is
a big deal that's a lot but it was
filled with something else and it was
filled with like a certain amount of
like love and commitment to both me and
something that they you know had passion
for it that's a crazy understanding at
the age five i mean i probably only see
that in retrospect but at the time i was
like you're awesome and i love you and i
miss you and i was fine that's dope as
hell it's dope for you just to have the
logic uh of course now because you're
older but then the wherewithal to just
be supportive right let's go back to you
now i mean success is happening right
you do your first movie oh my god this
is amazing but now there's a crazy talk
that's following you and people want to
work with you more movies are starting
to happen and one of the biggest things
come about right this twilight series
holy [ __ ] after this stardom really
takes off um what's your parents
feeling at this moment like you know now
you know our daughter is everywhere we
see her everywhere this is a business
that we grew up in and i grew up in that
we raised our daughter in and you know
we worked behind the scenes for quite
some time
wow our baby is
a baby is [ __ ] at the forefront of it
like this is a big deal what was their
conversations with you about that
um
so you like mentioned like that i seemed
kind of like i understood what they were
into and so that there was kind of an
understanding
whatever of their absence but
when i first like said to my mom
dude i think i like wanna go on a couple
auditions she was like what
you do not wanna do that oh wow it's
gonna be awful it's so okay because i
was super shy when i was little and like
not the obvious performer and
i think that she worked in
an environment in which she saw a lot of
people not have the greatest time
trying to be actors as little kids
and uh i was like
i was in some
like christmas performancy type thing
and having lived in la like there was
this
this thing where i was like you could
come learn how to do auditions okay and
you had to pay like three thousand
dollars to come learn how to do an
audition and then maybe have an
opportunity to go do an audition and i
was like i want to do that and she was
like this is a total ripoff and also
like you seem like shy and weird and
like a total backwards person are you
sure you want to do that
and i was like yeah i definitely do and
so she was like i'm taking a bet on you
right now so you have to pay me back if
it ever pays off but like i believe in
you
and do you know what my money is on you
kid and i was like this sounds like a
[ __ ] story no it doesn't
i was like
please i do want to try doing this i
think that's a that's a great form of
parenting that's like it's a it's a
reverse mind [ __ ]
i'm going to
support you but at the same time i'm
supporting you i'm telling you that i'm
investing in you that's what she said
she's like i'll make an investment in
you
[Music]
you